As you might expect, the rules surrounding
how one goes about donating one’s body FOR
SCIENCE varies a little from region to region,
though the general process and what happens
after you donate seems to be relatively consistent.
For instance, in the United Kingdom, donating
one’s body typically involves nothing more
than filling out a few forms provided by your
nearest university or medical school.
Under British law and the Human Tissue Act
of 2004, “written and witnessed consent”
is required prior to death for a medical authority
to claim a body and it’s highly recommended
that you make your family aware of your wishes
to expedite the process of transporting your
body after death.
The latter is important as it is possible
in the UK for your next of kin to override
your final wishes in regards to organ and
body donation, and just in general it’s
a good idea to process your body quickly lest
it get rejected for not being, for lack of
a better phrase, fresh enough.
Speaking of organ donation and body rejection,
in most cases being an organ donor whose organs
are harvested will disqualify you from subsequently
donating your body to science directly (though
there is a potential loophole in the United
States in going through a body broker, which
we’ll get to shortly).
However, it is possible to be both a body
and organ donor simultaneously regardless
of what side of the pond you’re on; in this
case, in the event that your organs are deemed
unsuitable for transplantation, the relevant
medical authority you’ve willed ownership
of your body to can then choose to take your
body or not at their discretion.
On that note, while there are no universal
rules for what condition your body has to
be in at the time of death for a medical authority
to be able to make use of it, a number of
things can exclude you immediately from being
considered.
For instance, you’ll almost certainly be
disqualified from donating your body if you
die of a communicable illness or “anything
that doesn’t have a known cause but which
may be communicable”.
In fact, among the first things done to donated
bodies, beyond refrigerating them to slow
decomposition, is to test them for any infectious
diseases.
After this, the body will typically be embalmed,
though there are exceptions to this, such
as if it’s being used for study on how the
body decomposes naturally over time in certain
scenarios, as is sometime done with CSI training
or investigation.
Another way your body will usually be disqualified
is if you die in a manner which renders it
in any way abnormal.
So, for example, if you die in a severe car
crash or from a disease which wastes away
your organs or muscle, it may be rejected
due to the fact that institutions accepting
bodies usually only want cadavers that are
representative of a healthy adult.
As one source puts it: “In a way, to successfully
donate your body, you have to be in perfect
health.
But dead.”
But, again, there are always exceptions and,
for example, researchers wanting to study
some disease or the effects of a given car
crash may be interested in your body, just
particularly in the latter case that can be
hard to arrange beforehand.
Even if your body is relatively unscathed
at the time of death, if you die under mysterious
or suspicious circumstances and an autopsy
needs to be performed, there’s a good chance
this too will result in your body being rejected.
Other things that can result in your body
being rejected, according to one non-exhaustive
list provided by the University of Liverpool
include: bedsores being present on your body
at the time of death, dying of an aortic aneurysm
and being obese.
Your body could also potentially be rejected
if the relevant medical authority simply has
no room for more bodies or you happen to die
at a time of year when nobody is around to
study your corpse in a relatively timely manner,
such as during the holidays in late December.
It’s also important to note that in the
event your body is rejected, the medical authority
you willed it to will take no responsibility
for your body’s disposal and the relevant
funerary costs will, thus, fall to your estate.
On the other hand, if your body is accepted,
the medical authority studying it will often,
depending on the wishes of you or your family,
cremate the remains free of charge, or otherwise
return them to your family for a private service
at your own expense.
Interestingly, because medical institutions
potentially cover the costs of the disposal
of your body, a not insignificant number Britons
have relatively recently started to opt into
donating their body “to science” in the
hopes that if their body is accepted, their
loved ones won’t have to pay expensive funeral
costs, which in Britain in 2016 averaged about
£3,702 (~$5,000) per funeral.
Over in the United States, the criteria for
donating a body to science is basically the
same and require you to sign a few forms signalling
consent prior to death and, again, it’s
a good idea to inform your family of your
wishes in regards to body disposal because,
as in the UK, the ultimate decision of what
happens to your body rests with your kin.
As the Forensic Anthropology Center of the
University of Tennessee puts it:
Regardless of what you have arranged, signed
or instructed, your family or next-of-kin
has the final say.
We will not fight your family for your body.
We urge you to convince your family that the
donation is what you want at your death.
Also like in the UK, certain factors can render
your body unsuitable for study and, for the
most part, they’re fairly comparable- death
from extreme trauma, infectious disease and
certain cancers can all cause your body to
be rejected, as can being obese.
On that note, most medical institutions in
the United States place a height and weight
limit on the cadavers they’ll accept, usually
limited to 6 feet (1.83 meters) and a max
of between 180-200 lbs (82-91 kg) depending
on the medical institution.
The main reasons for these restrictions are
practical in nature, with it being noted that
transporting obese bodies is more difficult
and that the medical tables typically used
aren’t large enough to accommodate pleasantly
plump corpses or those who’re very tall.
On top of this, dissecting obese bodies is
also more difficult owing to having to slice
through a lot of fat just to get to what’s
being studied.
Having organs and arteries and the like a
bit more accessible thanks to low body fat
percentage is just easier to work with.
Or, as Louisiana State University professor
Steven Heymsfield very frankly states, “When
you’re doing medical dissection, and you’re
up to your elbows in fat, it’s greasy and
unpleasant.”
In the UK, no such height limit is explicitly
specified in any literature we could find,
although especially large persons (either
in regards to height or weight) are advised
that their bodies might be rejected, with
the common reason listed being difficulty
in moving the body.
Unlike Britons, thanks to competition for
bodies being stiff in the states, American
citizens who are somewhat petite have a great
deal of choice when it comes to donating their
body to science.
And if you’re now wondering why competition
is high in the land of the descendants of
traitors to the British crown, besides the
larger number of institutions needing bodies,
only a small fraction of the 100 million or
so people who opt into organ donation end
up opting to alternately donate their body
to science.
This is despite full body donation arguably
being just as beneficial as organ donation,
if not more so in some cases in that the benefit
to science can potential help many people,
instead of just a maximum of a handful as
in organ donation.
(And, note, as with organ donation, a single
body can, and often is, used for several research
projects.)
As the Associate Director for Education at
Indiana University School of Medicine, Ernest
Talarico, notes, “You literally help tens
of thousands, hundreds of thousands with donation.
It’s not only those who learn from you;
it’s also the research and those who learn
from the research.”
Because of the high need for bodies, some
companies in the U.S. have made a fortune
acting as a middleman of sorts between families
and scientific institutions.
Said companies generally offer to pay the
costs of cremation and the transportation
and storage of the body to and from wherever
it is needed.
For instance, Science Care has taken the idea
to its logical extreme, comparing themselves
to McDonald’s in that they deliver a product
(in this case, human bodies and body parts)
of consistent quality regardless of where
the institution wanting the body or body part
is in the country.
In fact, it’s reported from 2012-2014 alone,
Science Care brought in a cool $12.5 million
selling human remains, which is only publicly
known due to certain court filings.
Another body broker, Research for Life, notes
they typically get about “$2,500-$3,000”
profit per full body.
As for gross cost, documents from another
body broker, Biological Resource Center, showed
they were charging $5,893 per whole body in
2013, but could potentially make more if slicing
the body up.
For instance, they listed a price of $1,900
for a spine, $3,500 for a torso, and $1,300
for a leg…
One of the main controversies with such for-profit
body brokers is that it’s not clear how
many of the people signing up to them realise
these companies generate income by selling
body parts (or whole bodies) from those who
donate their deceased selves to the companies.
To be fair, though, it should be noted that,
at least in the case of Science Care, their
donor consent form does explicitly state the
for-profit nature of the company.
And for those wanting to increase the odds
that their family won’t have to shell out
any money for disposing of one’s remains,
companies like these do offer a reasonably
good outlet.
As previously noted, some body brokers also
allow you to donate your organs first and
then they take the rest of you to sell off
at their discretion.
With most all of these companies, though,
you just have to understand that what happens
to your body after they get it isn’t generally
something you or your loved ones have much
say in.
For instance, certain of these organizations
have taken advantage of the fact that there
is little in the way of oversight in the body
donation industry (unlike organ donation,
which is regulated), sometimes using bodies
in ways explicitly against the wishes of the
deceased when they filled out the paper work.
Other such companies simply note right on
the application form that they can’t be
sure what your body or body parts will ultimately
be used for.
So, as with everything in life, even in death,
if you’re getting a product for free, odds
are reasonable you’re the product.
It’s just that in this case the old adage
is a little more literal than usual.
Some people, of course, have a huge problem
with such for-profit body broker companies,
while others are just happy to maximize the
odds of their loved ones not having to pay
for an expensive burial or cremation, caring
little about what’s done with their corpse.
Moving swiftly on, whether donating to a medical
institution directly or to a body broker,
there’s a wide range of career options available
to the discerning corpse, not just in giving
medical students incredibly valuable practice
working on a human body that doesn’t care
if they screw up.
As for these dead body career options, doctors
may use your body to train in some new and
innovative surgical method or with some new
piece of equipment.
Being able to use your corpse for this can
be a huge benefit in reducing the risk of
mistakes when operating on the living.
A somewhat more exciting cadaver career path
can be found at the University of Tennessee’s
Forensic Anthropology Center where they have
been watching bodies decompose in various
ways for about three decades now.
(If you live within 200 miles and they accept
your body, they’ll even transport it for
free.)
One of the many ways in which they might use
your body is to mimic various ways in which
people are murdered and then just observe
the effects on your body, possibly even over
spans of many years.
They also might use a living picture of you
to observe the change in your visage to help
them figure out how a given corpse probably
looked in life.
This and many other such experiments provide
incredibly valuable data to a variety of fields,
most notably in this case crime scene investigation.
If being murdered after you die and then observed
as you decompose isn’t your thing, when
you donate your body, some institutions allow
for selecting to donate for “Safety Testing”.
If you check that box, your body then may
be used as a crash test dummy.
While this might seem a bit bizarre if you’ve
never heard of it before, the use of dead
bodies in car safety testing is something
every car manufacturer benefits from when
testing some new safety device or car design.
Although, when asked, most seem prone to outright
deny they test in this way.
For some, it’s technically true that they
don’t in that they may simply donate funds
to various medical institutions that in turn
at the behest of the company and the National
Highway Traffic Administration use bodies
to test various cars and car safety equipment.
So it’s not technically the car company
doing it.
Depending on the nature of the deal, the data
collected may be available to all car companies
(and the public) or, in some cases, such as
with Ford’s inflatable seat belts, the information
may only be shared with the company and the
National Highway Traffic Administration.
In these proprietary cases, the information
is declared by the company as confidential
business information so that it’s not even
available through a Freedom of Information
Act request to the NHTA.
Perhaps gruesome to some, use of your body
in this way can potentially save thousands
of lives, as no artificial crash test dummy
perfectly mimics the human body like, well,
a human body can.
As former Ford safety researcher Priya Prasad
notes, “Even though we have very good math
modeling of dummies, human modeling hasn’t
reached that state yet.”
(For anyone wondering, we checked and as far
as we can tell neither Ferrari nor Lamborghini
offer such a program.
That could mean they really don’t use human
bodies in crash tests, or it could mean they,
like seemingly all major car companies, don’t
like to admit they do or otherwise fund such
research on their cars.
Either way, given the number of non-sports
car models produced is much greater than the
blazing fast variety, keep in mind that if
you opt to have your body used in safety testing
and you’re selected for crash testing, your
corpse will probably end up stuck driving
a rather boring family car.)
Beyond crash tests, there are countless other
ways in which your body might be used if you
opt for safety testing, including in testing
various helmet types.
In fact, some dead people’s heads are presently
being used to design better helmets for those
who participate in American Football- as you
can imagine, the NFL is particularly interested
in this line of research, but it’s also
potentially massively beneficial for the many
thousands of teens who play the sport.
In the end, if something is used to protect
a human in some way and it’s made by a major
corporation, odds are strong at some point
said device was tested on dead people, generally
via grants given to medical institutions who
actually have access to the bodies.
If having your head put in prototype helmets
and bashed up against hard surfaces or having
your body involved in a mini-van crash isn’t
your thing, another, slightly more badass
sounding, option is to donate your body to
a medical institution and, assuming the option
is available, opt into use by the military.
If accepted, your body will likely be loaded
with state of the art sensors and then used
to help test new weapons and armor, or just
used in things like testing a given explosion’s
affect on a human body.
Yes, if you’d like to help protect the troops
or to help in the design of weapons for making
more bodies, you too can potentially have
your corpse blown up FOR MILITARY SCIENCE!
Or, if you’re more of a pacifist, you may
have the option to spend the afterlife as
a skeleton…
But not like other skeletons- a skeleton examined
by countless researchers.
Yes, there are numerous anthropology departments
across America who can take your body and
strip it down to such for study and research.
In these cases, of course, your skeleton will
likely not be cremated or otherwise returned
to your loved ones.
On this note, the University of Tennessee
currently boasts an impressive collection
over around 1,000 full human skeletons, noting,
“Every individual donated to the skeletal
collection is also used to educate, train
and provide a resource for research in forensic
taphonomy…”
And for the extreme exhibitionists among you,
it’s even possible to donate your body,
or at least part of it, to be put on public
display.
Besides the famed Body Worlds exhibition,
The Mutter Museum in Philadelphia is one such
option for such.
So to sum up, whatever you’d like your body
to be used for once you’re done with it,
donating your body “to science” is simply
a matter of first contacting a relevant authority
or institution- usually your local medical
school is your best bet, though if you just
want the free body disposal and don’t care
what’s done with your corpse, a body broker
isn’t necessarily a bad option.
Either way, you’ll then only need to fill
out a few quick forms to signal your consent
to make it happen.
And best to also explicitly mention to your
loved ones that those are your wishes to make
sure things go smoothly after you die.
Also, for most every option, you should generally
plan that your estate may need to at the least
pay for transport of your body, and possibly
that your body will be rejected when the time
comes, meaning funds for a more typical body
disposal will be needed.
And, hey, if your body is accepted and the
institution chooses to go ahead and handle
all the fees, that’s just extra money freed
up for use by your loved ones to throw a better
party in your honour with.
It’s speculated that the likely reasons
for the large disparity between people opting
into organ donation vs. full body donation
in the United States are that donating one’s
entire body is somewhat stigmatized, rather
than celebrated as in organ donation; arranging
to donate your body requires slightly more
effort than just checking a box on a form
when renewing your license or the like; and
the average American male particularly simply
has a body outside of the height/weight range
usually accepted by medical institutions (max
of ~180-200 lbs and 6ft tall).
For reference here, the average adult American
male rings in at about 195 pounds and 5 feet
10 inches (1.8 meters) tall according to the
CDC.
Given that this is more the norm than the
more physically fit bodies many medical students
and doctors practice on, there has been some
call of late to start accepting bodies with
a bit more girth and height so said medical
students will end up getting more first-hand
experience with the type of bodies they’re
likely to frequently work on in their career.
However, the practical side of things still
rules the day at present, though many institutions
are starting to transition to bigger tables
and particularly loosening their guidelines
on weight restriction on accepted bodies.
As professor Heymsfield goes on to state,
“I don’t think you need a room full of
obese cadavers, but I still think there’s
a usefulness for students.
I think to give them a sense of what the effects
of obesity can be on a person’s body.
There’s nothing like the real thing.”